the southern desert regional police
academy held a graduation today at the
college of southern nevada very exciting
stuff jeremy j ford attended as 12
graduates were represented by several
agencies
it's real it's not no strong park lanson
decosta is now a police officer whose
journey to becoming one started in high
school i went to high school at veterans
tribute career technical academy where i
majored in law enforcement eventually
becoming a corrections officer wanting
to change lives i worked at ndoc for two
years and i realized i wanted to do more
and help a lot of the guys that were in
there to stay out of prison decosta
decided to join the southern desert
regional police academy and along with
11 other recruits became an officer of
the law
[Applause]
[Music]
so they'll head to their prospective
agencies they will then start their
advanced academy training prior to them
going into field training where they'll
spend about four more weeks before
becoming a solo officer it's still just
the beginning so there's still going to
be a lot of like troubles to get over
but it's a nice relief to know at least
this chapter is over with as officer
andrea flinter starts her career she
offers this advice
to not categorize all the police
officers we're human it's going to be
bad people in every profession can't
judge everybody based off of one person
while on a journey to serve and protect
our city i definitely want them to fill
a purpose i want them to understand that
there's a need for them there's a desire
for them to be in this community and
that they are
supported jeremy j ford live local now